thank you so I'll be talking about
near-optimal bootstrapping of fitting
sets so joint work with maternal coma
and animating say some of you who wear a
duck stool this is going to be a very
similar talk so the talk is going to be
about algebraic circuits so algebraic
circuits are objects of this sort they
compute a polynomial in the natural day
I'm not going to go more into this so we
don't think that happens with the new
happening just blur yeah so I'll focus
on just formulas just for just for
simplicity but almost everything that
I'm going to be saying today just works
for any reasonable class that we care
about so there's a tree made up of these
things but I'm going to sort of define
the formula size to be the number of
leaves of the formula and this is up to
constant factors so it doesn't make much
of a difference the reason I'm going to
use this as the measure of complexity is
because it sort of behaves nicely when
we do compositions that is what I want
to say is that if I have a formula
computing F and two its variables i plug
in formulas of small size then the total
formulas I sort of becomes a product
where it's just the size of F times the
largest size of G it's just easier to
see if it's working if you work with the
number of leaves
that's the only reason and we use the
notation formula of nd comma s to refer
to the class of all N variate
polynomials of degree at most D that are
computable by formulas of a size at most
s and similarly if I write circuits here
I mean we know what that means okay so
the polynomial 90 degree question is
that no you're given the formula of this
type and then you you want to know
whether the the polynomial computed by
it is the zero polynomial or not so
there are two versions of this one where
you basically are given the formula in
the sense that you know what the wirings
are what the constants etcetera are so
that you can inspect the formula and
then make your decision or the
the stronger form is what is called
black box identity testing where you
have provided a black box with some very
basic parameters to sort of say that you
know in this black box is a no is a
formula that has these parameters and
the only thing you can really do is you
have evaluation access and that's what
you do so basically this is equivalent
to the question of constructing heating
sets for for this class which is a just
to recall the heating set is basically
just a list of points such that every
nonzero polynomial in this class is
guaranteed to evaluate to a nonzero
value on one of these points okay so now
the goal is therefore to construct
rating sets so first let's ask ourselves
do there exist heating sets of small
size and the simple counting argument
will basically say that as long as your
model is anything reasonable that is the
description of your model is small there
will always be non explicit hitting sets
of polynomial size whether it's formulas
or circuits or whatever so that what we
want to know is like are there explicit
hitting sets of small sizes or not and
there is there is a trivial heating set
but this is bad
in the sense that it follows from this
sort of odd ml or depth range one triple
lemma which basically says that if you
have a non zero polynomial of degree D
then it will evaluate to a non zero
value on a grid of side length D plus
one so so if you just take a grid of
side length D plus 1 then this is
already going to be a hitting set for
any degree D polynomial irrespective of
whether or not the size is at most s or
whatever this is completely independent
of the side so we have it we have a sort
of a explicit hitting set but this is a
trivial exponential size dating set of
this much size and so the question is
going to be like are there small hitting
sets if I know that I am working with
formulas or circuits or something of
bounded size so and so earlier this year
later last year so Agarwal Gaussian
Saxena proved this really cool result
which says the following so let us
assume the following so let's say that
you know suppose for every s bigger than
or equal to n you look
the class of circuits that have sy the
size s circuits of degree up on n
variables and I am just going to assume
that the degree is bounded by the size
of the circuit and suppose you can
construct a hitting set of size which is
something like s plus 1 to the root n so
think of it as saying that the trivial
hitting set must have had side s plus s
plus 1 to the N and now we are saying
that you want to improve the exponent to
something smaller than routing and
suppose you could do this then they
showed that you can actually use this to
construct an explicit hitting set for
almost polynomial size where this tiny
is a really slow growing function if you
care about what this function is it's
like it's a double exponential in this
log start function where log star is
defined as the number of times you need
to keep taking logs for it to drop below
1 or something what's a few log star
among friends so so this says that you
know if you have some sort of no not too
bad hitting said then you can somehow
use this to construct a really really
strong hitting set and what we do in
this work is improved this in two
aspects so the first aspect is that
suppose you could give me a hitting set
which is sort of barely non-trivial the
sense that the exponent is the trivial
bound would have been n but I just want
something anything better than n so the
point naught 1 is no special number it
could be any number there in fact you
could even put a 1 over log N or
something
it's just that just beat the trivial the
trivial hitting set by whatever remote
and we can get the same sort of
conclusion as eight years
so the thing so basically you need to
make some dent in the exponent so that
is you are sort of it's it's a question
of how much in factors of s are you
saving so in fact this n even if you can
do this first let us say like by way
elect n equal to two this is fine so I
can write the statement but it will sort
of not be very useful in the sense that
in the course of the proof we trivially
we sort of crucially use the fact that
this is we are going to use this
hypothesis for a lot of circuits and
there will be points when the degree and
the number of variables will number the
degree and the size will get very close
to each other so I would need the
hypothesis like for example if it is the
case that you are working with circuits
of much smaller degree then we trivially
know sort of how - I mean if degree was
much smaller than s then we already have
the trivial heating set already seems to
be better but the proof will use regimes
even when D is very very close to us so
which is why I am stating this in this
regime
oh you just like real oh one sunny like
a little oh one advantage know that that
thing could be won by login if you want
n minus 1 by log in is that will also
get the same conclusion yeah so the
thing is I mean like I don't want the
exponent to have anything to do with s
this is the this is going to be very
crucial like the gain is like what is
like 1 over 2 to the N for example sure
that's fine yeah I just want it for some
time think of n the hypothesis is going
to start with n equal to some constant
and all I'm saying is that just read
anything non-trivial but for every s
that's the important part
the flow I should have put it as
circuits of s comma s comma s I'm sorry
yeah okay so this is one improvement
which is we just improve what you need
for the hang the hypothesis to get the
same conclusion and another thing that
comes out of our proof is that the same
result also holds if your hypothesis
works for let's say some restricted
class like say formulas or even
branching programs or something
basically as long as you have a class
which is sort of well behaved under
compositions projections sums and so on
this result will we'll just go okay what
time do I stop okay so okay good so by
explicit what I mean is if if the final
hitting setters of a certain size there
is an algorithm that runs an poly in
that size that outputs that hitting set
okay so a very very high level view of
how this proof works is that you're just
going to make use of this hardness
verses randomness paradigm that is it's
sort of well known that the task of
constructing non-trivial hitting sets
and the task of constructing explicit
lower bounds are very intimately
connected to each other and so to go
from a non-trivial hitting set to a
lower bound this was observed by Heinz
and Schneider and agribon so that's this
part and to go from an explicit lower
bound to a hitting set so this was
observed by cabinets and impact Laird so
I mean okay and what we are going to do
is basically just keep going around and
around this thing so what we'll do is
we'll start with a non-trivial hitting
set get a decent lower bound
use that lower bound to get a slightly
better hitting set and get a better
lower one and we're just going to keep
repeating this process okay so in order
to describe it I mean like I first
probably need to mention what Heinz and
snorted and what cabinets and puck
layers are a bit so I'll spend a fair
amount of time trying to just give an
exposition of those results and then see
why you can actually do this and and
also see why something like this seems
to be unlikely in the boolean world but
in the algebraic world you somehow
somehow mint money okay okay good so
I'll just do I will go into the
preliminaries it's just the hardness
randomness trade-off
so the easier thing to describe is the
Heinz and Schnoor thing so I'll do that
first
so suppose we knew that we had a hitting
set for some Class C here and what is
the definition the definition says that
every nonzero polynomial must evaluate
to a nonzero value on one of these
points so the contrapposto of this is
that if I can find a polynomial that is
actually zero on every point in H then
by definition it cannot be a member of
this class now ideally I would want to
say okay this gives me a lower bond but
it could not be a member of this class
for a stupid reason in the sense that
maybe the degree is larger than D so in
a sense that so what Hynes and snort
said was like if your size of the
hitting set is not too large
then you will be able to find one
polynomial that vanishes on all these
points of small degree and that will
tell you that it's not a member of this
class because the size required for it
is large and this gives you a size lower
and there's a lot of room in choosing
how many variables versus the degree you
want here and this is going to be
crucial in in our PID construction ok so
this is just a one slide overview of
pension or cool so now I'm going to go
into cabinets and populate so this will
take a bit more time but this is the
going to be the informal statement which
is that suppose you knew that Q was hard
enough in the sense that it required
large circuits to compute it or
something then if I in place of x1
through XM I substitute values I mean I
substitute this Q but not on disjoint
variables but on almost disjoint
variables this will somehow preserve the
nonzero nests of the polynomial in the
sense that it's hard for a small circuit
to figure out that what is plugged in is
some correlated versions of a hard
polynomial so this is like an algebraic
analog of the Nissan and big drifts in
hardness randomness trade-offs in the
boolean world so maybe let's just take a
few minutes to sort of describe what
this almost disjoint means these are
going to be defined by what are called
combinatorial designs it's possible a
lot of people know this I'm going to do
this anyway because it's cool
so combinatorial design is just a
collection of subsets of a universe such
that they're pairwise intersections are
small ok so formally I will say a
collection of sets is an LKR design to
mean that L is the L is saying that
these all come from a universe of size L
and K is saying that each set is of size
K and R is a strict upper bound on
pairwise intersections where here I is
not equal to J and so these are called
combinatorial designs and we would like
to construct such designs there are
plenty of ways to do this I mean like
you can just use the probabilistic
method to do this if you want and
the way to phrase it in terms of codes
and what I'm going to describe is one
sort of very hands-on construction which
will which will be useful which is
essays that you know for all L that is
bigger than K square there are always
going to be designed so this this many
sets like think of L as just being K
squared so there are going to be designs
of K to the are sets the achieve these
things there's a very simple
construction which is what we are going
to do is we are going to assume that L
over K is a prime or a prime power and
identify this with a field and I'm going
to look at basically like F cross F
that's going to be my universe but I'll
restrict myself to maybe the first K
columns so I have a universe of size N
and every set is going to be defined by
a univariate polynomial of degree less
than R and the set is basically just the
graph of this polynomial so it's just
the point it's just a collection of
points I comma P or Phi where you range
I from 1 through K so clearly the each
set is of size K they all belong to a
universe of size L and so different
polynomials will give rise to different
sets and just this basic fact that two
degree are -1 polynomials can agree in
utmost R minus 1 places tells you that
the pairwise intersection is going to be
small extremely simple construction and
this is the construction that they are
going to be using are there any
questions so far
there'll be points when so there will be
points when it's important that this is
K to the are and not to to be R that's
the only thing but otherwise we don't
really
yeah okay okay so now that we know what
this is the notion of pairwise sort of
almost disjoint or whatever so I'm going
to use this notation just to simplify
things so so Q of L K comma R I'm going
to think of it as a vector of
polynomials which are basically what we
want to plug in in the cabinets and
pavilion so reading that is I want to
plug in the evaluation of Q on almost
disjoint sets what I'm going to mean by
that is there's going to be some set of
L variables and this is just the vector
it's just the Q applied on each
restriction of these L variables
depending on what your design is it's
just notation we'll keep using again and
again okay so here is the main lemma of
community name Park layer to say it's
that let P be some nonzero polynomial of
degree capital D and suppose and it has
a small circuit and suppose Q is a cave
Ariat polynomial of individual degree
less than T by that I mean the degree in
every variable in Q is less than small T
and suppose it so happens that when I
plug this in I got the zero polynomial
then it must be the case that Q has
small circuits this is the key lemma
kavanah to do and it just give a quick
proof of this because we will have to
come up with a version of this for
formulas or a B piece or something okay
so here's what you do so you start off
with P which I know to begin with is a
nonzero polynomial and I want to make
the substitution but I'm going to do the
substitution slowly so the first thing I
do is replace x1 by the corresponding Q
maybe it remains nonzero now I try to do
x2 maybe it remains nonzero now I try to
do x3 and maybe not this point the
circuits are only became 0 so I'm going
to step back and sort of keep and tell
myself that x3 is going to be an
important variable and the set s 3 is
going to be important I basically want
to get rid of everything else that's
happening right now so right now I have
a nonzero polynomial which let me call P
tilde which depends on the X variables
and the Y variables
but I split it in sort of what I want
and what I don't want so I'm going to
write it as x3 and the rest
and similarly why restricted to s3 and
the rest so the first thing we'll do is
we'll get rid of the X rest variables by
plugging grant plugging value such that
the nonzero Ness continues to hold so
the so now it depends on just X 3 and
the y variables the next thing I want to
do is get rid of this the Y rest
variables by plugging in value such that
nonzero Ness is preserved again now the
point is earlier these were all Q's
evaluated at various these subsets
but the moment I substitute everything
outside of s3 whatever this polynomial
is it's going to depend only on the
variables that actually belonged in s3
and so therefore this this is I don't
care what this polynomial is but it's
some polynomial of individual degree at
most B that depends on at most R minus 1
variables because I know that the
pairwise intersections are small so what
I'm going to do is I'm just going to
brute force and say that now let me just
write down a trivial circuit for that at
these points because I can offer two
because R minus 1 in some sense is small
enough so let's just compute the size of
this whole thing and let's call this
polynomial P prime what's the size of
this whole circuit so so the size is
like I started off with a circuit of
sizes and now I need to plug in whatever
is at the bottom and what I need to plug
in is some polynomial of individual
degree at most D on R minus 1 variables
the number of monomials is D power R
minus 1 each monomial to write down I
might need something like D R so this is
the size that I will require for each of
these small slivers so that tells me
that so total size of P prime is small
and the degree is also small we made
some progress now what do we know if we
replace X 3 by Q this polynomial is
becoming 0 that means that X 3 minus Q
must divide this polynomial P Prime and
at this point you can just use the
factorization algorithms to sort of say
that factors of small circuits are small
circuits and extract X 3 minus Q you
don't really need Cal toughen result
here because you
we only care about the existence of
small circuits for factors we don't
really care about an algorithm to get a
small circuit so there's a simpler proof
of pita beauty search so you could just
use this and pull out X 3 minus Q and
set X 3 equal to zero and that will that
basically finishes the proof of cabinets
and furniture so just to write down if
this happens this is the formal
statement that is the size that you end
up getting is going to be whatever the
size of this P prime is power order 1
because of whatever this factorization
algorithm yes there any questions so far
so basically now what I want to do is
this is what happens for in the circuit
world this hardness was the randomness
trade-off but ideally you would want to
do this over say formulas or a bps or
something and let's ask ourselves what
goes wrong and okay sorry before this
let me just write the contrapositive
which is just to sort of put it in the
perspective of what we had last time did
you say that if Q did not have small
circuits if Q was hard enough then the
non zero Ness is preserved so now why
does this not work for other models like
formulas so the thing is I do not know I
know that factors of small circuits have
small circuits but I do not know if
factors of small formulas have small
formulas and this is the reason why I
cannot apply if I was working with
formulas I cannot apply can't often even
ABP we do not know both these things
seem to have an end to the log and blow
up just best this is the best upper
bound we can prove currently for a BPU
respect I don't know I think it should
it should be closed under factoring but
we don't have a proof currently but I
just want to get a heightened I just
don't want to do factoring basically so
let's step back and just tell ourselves
that so far if we were working with
formulas P prime has a formula of this
much size up until now everything is
fine okay I can compute Q I know or at
least I do not know how to compute Q so
I'm going to try to do something a
little something else which is to
compute a multiple of Q so basically
what I want to do is in some
since B prime is already a multiple of Q
almost that is if I can set x3 equal to
zero then I would compute something
which is a multiple of Q there's just
one catch that it's possible that P
prime is divisible by x3 but you can use
interpolation to sort of divide it out
and then make the substitution and right
so what you end up getting is that if it
is the case that if you start off with
the sizes formula and such a
substitution ended up giving you the 0
polynomial may not be able to say that Q
has a size for small formula but I'll be
able to say that a low degree multiple
of Q will have a small formula ok and so
so what's the contrapositive of this
this is like saying that if Q has the
property that it's hard in a more robust
sense that is it's not just that Q is
computable five small formulas or it's
not computable by small formulas that
low degree multiples of Q are also not
computable by small formulas then this
gives you a way of preserving nonzero
Nessun and sort of doing this you know
why would something like this be useful
the important point is if Q is hard
because it vanished on a heating set
then multiples of Q also vanishes on a
heating set so they would also be hard
for the same reasons and this is what we
are going to keep using so you're going
to build hard polynomials that come from
heating sets because that way I can use
the robustness of this hardness so say
that it's not just that Q is hard but as
long as I mean for some slack I mean
even though even multiples of Q will be
hard and basically this is going to
allow us to do the hardness randomness
trade-offs even for models like formula
has or a BP
rather than any questions so far so this
is at least this should sort of say that
you know an analog like this should
hopefully work for formulas if we start
off with a good cue
okay excellent so right so this gives us
a way of sort of taking the hitting set
for here for K variate polynomials use
that to construct a hard polynomial and
somehow use that to do a variable
reduction and therefore give a hitting
set for m variate formulas this is
something they're going to be using a
lot will make this more formal okay so
here is a typical template for this
hardness randomness trade-off
okay the hypothesis will often say that
you know I have a hard polynomial a very
hard polynomial that's usually a little
harder than what you want to construct
the hitting set for so if you want a
hitting set for say MSS you will need
something that is sort of something like
s to the C hard where C is some constant
or something okay and what do you do you
first construct a design and then you
use the hardness of Q to argue that this
sort of substitution preserves nonzero
nests and once you do this oh sorry this
is this must be M not L so once you do
this you are left with some polynomial
on just L variables so just brute-force
over that this is how the typical sort
of hardness randomness thing works so in
our case what we are going to have is
the hypothesis is not a hard polynomial
but the hypothesis is going to be a
hitting set for some smaller L so we do
the same first step but now we use the
hypothesis to construct a hard
polynomial Q we do this from heinsch
naught so that we have something that is
more robust and then we will sort of say
that in all the nonzero nests is
preserved and finally one last step
instead of brute forcing over this I can
just use the hypothesis again because
this circuit will turn out to not be
like too large I mean it will be
smallish so you can use the hypothesis
again and you somehow start with some
heating set and you can somehow get a
better heating set for a larger size I
mean for a larger number of variables
and this is basically what we are going
to do and just we are just going to keep
doing this again and again if you look
at it I don't know if this is top down
maybe if you look at the bottom up
this would be an iteration of a basic
theology yes if you look at it from the
bottom up this looks like a iteration of
those basic PRG so at every step you are
going to apply and design you keep doing
this and at the bottom you're just going
to use your hypothesis yeah so the
choice of the polynomial Q is because of
to just keep working with generators
there is a silly dating better yeah I
mean everything anything reasonable
should work so if you if you are if you
care about circuits you don't need any
of this you could have just done
no so yes for a technical reason and
anyway we'll see all right okay let me
rephrase I do not know if we can do it I
mean
right I don't know of a way of starting
with the hypothesis being a white box
thing together okay
so let me talk a little bit about wide
why does bootstrapping work I mean this
seems like something weird is happening
like they're just getting something for
free and I want to talk a little bit
about it so let's start with the regime
when you want to you want to do PID for
a poli-sci circuit that is you start off
with a circuit which is something like
impart five size or something okay so
for this what you would have to do is
find the k variate polynomial wave
scales like order log n which is sort of
reasonably hard so that you can do a
variable reduction from M variables to
something like lock squared and
variables is what you want to do now
what bootstrapping is suggesting is just
saying that let's look at this new
polynomial that we get after this
variable substitution and what is really
stopping us from doing this again the
problem is that right now earlier s was
polynomial in M but s / s prime is going
to be slightly larger than s but if I
look at it in terms of the number of
variables this is already exponential in
the number of variables and this feels
like you know this is going to be a
problem because now in order to apply
this again I will need to find a hard
polynomial which is sort of a very hard
polynomial where K is now going to be
like log L but then it has to sort of be
doubly exponentially hard in terms of K
this would be K again okay
that's sort of what you want and this
seems like you know this is like a feels
like a losing battle because for
instance if you are doing this in the
boolean world I mean you can't hope for
hardness that is beyond exponential
because every boolean function on L
variables will have a circuit of size at
most here but here the point is in the
algebraic world you can play with the
degrees I mean it's possible that you
working with L variate polynomials but
of possibly large degrees so it sort of
makes sense to ask if no does this
polynomial have a double exponential in
L sighs circuit maybe because the degree
is also of the order of the same thing
and this is really in I mean in some
sense this is sort of what allows us to
do this bootstrapping and so I the
message of this whole thing is that
there is really nothing stopping you
from doing this bootstrapping again
again you just need to be you just need
to be using the degree of the polynomial
you are working with as well this is
important this is the my opinion the key
difference between what is happening in
the algebraic world versus what is
happening at the boolean world okay so
in the remaining 10 minutes what I want
to do is I want to try and give a full
proof and the full proof will basically
follow this plan so we'll start off with
a hitting set that sort of barely
non-trivial I mean we'll start off with
this assumption that for every is
greater than or equal to n naught we
have a hitting set of this much size
this I'll first I'll show that you can
get to a slightly better state which is
now you're hitting set size is going to
be n by 50 instead of n minus 0.1 or
something like that but this n1 will be
larger than n not something like N and
not n1 will be like n not Park 10 or
something like that the next step would
be to get to a point where it is
something like polynomially I mean the
exponent is sort of polynomial a better
than brute force
fourth root of n or something like this
and at this point we are just going to
use the machinery that AGS a crevalle
coercion saxena high and they had this
nice lemma that says that suppose you
hired a hitting set where this G of n
was substantially smaller than root N
and using n to the 1/4 just to make the
calculations easy ok then you can get a
new hitting set for something like that
looks like where the exponent looks like
G with a poly with a log inside
intuitively so basically what this
allows you to do is that you can now
repeat this process because the new H of
M will also satisfy the same hypothesis
and you can keep inserting logs inside
the running time I mean inside the
exponent and this is what they call
bootstrapping and that will give the
result that you want
ok
there is something how do you farm land
yeah so there are group Al Gore Saxena
worked only for circuits but if you
replace their the vanilla version of
cabinets impact layer job is this
version this gives you I mean this just
recovers a curve Al Gore Saxena yeah so
this is the this is going to be the plan
of the rest of the thing yeah so the
here the n naught can be I mean you can
start off with even and not being too
and so on and here at one step of the
iteration will make will increase it by
something like a not part n one step of
the iteration will again increase it by
another n not part n but from here on
the increases exponentially and
eventually in log star steps you will
reach whatever s that you want that's
the high level picture of what spawns
it's a question of compared to what I
mean like the yeah yeah but there's a so
you'll see what happens in the proof and
little okay so what I'm going to do is I
will first give a proof of this lemma
which is which is basically what AG has
hide and we'll see what happens so so
this is the formal definition formal
statement of NGSS lemma which is that
suppose n is large enough in this case
it's going it has to be large enough by
some amount and you had a hitting set
that was sort of better than root n so
here I'm going to work with n PI 1/4
just to make life easy ok then you have
a hitting set for whatever n you start
off with you now work you have a hitting
set for m variate polynomials where m is
exponentially larger than n but the
running time doesn't degrade by too much
so somehow you your M the number of
variables increased massively but the
heating said sort heating sets is sort
of degraded very very little
and if you just start with this and keep
applying this process again and again
but it's sort of easy to sort of see
that now if you start up whatever n
naught and use now repeat this again and
again you see a double exponential and
log star coming up simple calculation
I'm not going to bother about this okay
so what's the proof of this lemma I'm
going to give that M and we're going to
follow the template that I described
earlier if you don't follow it once it's
fine I'm going to do the same thing
three times slightly different
parameters and we'll see what happens
okay so this is the hypothesis I have an
S to the GN sized rating set for this
plus that G of n is at most n to the 1/4
over time so you first pick a design and
these design parameters is really what
will change in the three here it's like
the universe is of size n each set is of
size root N and the pairwise
intersection is like n to the one foot
constant or something
not in this so this is the bootstrapping
lemma where we'll keep applying it again
and again so there will be points when
this n also becomes throwing yes yes so
right now let's say that n is some fixed
thing we have somehow constructed a
hitting set up till size N and I now
want to construct the hitting set for
size n so it's not size I mean then I
have n variate polynomials I have a
hitting set I now want to consider
hitting set for m variate polynomials
where m is exponentially larger okay so
I start with such a head except now what
I do is I use the heating set for size s
n it should be thought of as independent
variables yeah n NS are two independent
things here okay you start off with the
heating set for size s power 5 and use
that to construct your heart polynomial
this is the final step and the
individual degree will turn out to be
whatever the size of the hitting set is
divided by K the number of ways
okay so I'm using a heating set on n
variables but constructing a polynomial
that just depends on K variables but
just think of it as Q is just
masquerading to be an N variate
polynomial when it's really just a cave
variable and you use the hardness claim
to sort of say that I want to say that
this preserves nonzero nice why is that
notice that Q vanish Donna heating's we
need Q to vanish on a heating set of
size D prime as prime for this claim to
work and fortunately our choice of s
power 5 was enough to account for these
things and then Bob's your uncle so we
know that you know the nonzero Ness of
the polynomial is preserved and at this
point we just observe that how large is
this polynomial even after the
substitution the old size was s and this
is some polynomial of individual degree
at most this in like K variables okay so
it has yeah it has at most this much
size so put this all together and this
you can sort of use the hypothesis again
for that completes the proof of the main
bootstrapping level so this already
tells you that if you could do s to the
n to the 1/4 you can get to s to the
tiny of s yes because the idea is I need
to I mean for this to be explicit I need
to sort of say what the hitting set is
for the new okay so I need to sort of
plug in Q via this yes yeah I mean I I I
mean I need a circuit for Q so that I
know I know what to plug in so just what
you need to do is evaluate Q yes yes yes
yes I basically need to so whatever the
hitting set for the L variate case I
need to evaluate Q on the corresponding
points and feed that as my m variate
fitting set so all that I need to know q
explicitly
okay so this finishes this part so let's
do this part and this is going to be
basically the same thing okay so this is
the now this is the hypothesis we are
working with so I have an S to the G of
n size fitting set that G of n is like n
by 50 and again I want to get a I want
to get to the end to the one fourth type
regime now we are going to do a slightly
different design that is K is going to
be n L is going to be like N squared and
think of our to be 10 I mean intuitively
the point is I only need a stretch of
something like from K to K power n so I
can sort of offered are being very small
good exactly the same thing I mean you
work with now with you take the hitting
set for size s part 5 and somehow show
that it's nonzero why is it why does it
present non zero Ness Bob's your uncle
yeah and this will tell you that you
know the non-zero ness is preserved
after you make such a substitution
because you'll be you'll be well within
the sort of guarantees you need okay
okay now what now the point is I would
one thing seems to be that maybe we can
try to use the hypothesis again but we
can actually do something even more
stupid which is I can just say that now
this new polynomial is some polynomial
on else l equals which I ll which is N
squared variables and it's degree is not
too large if you plug in the values so I
can just use SWAT simple right now I
mean like I can just say that you know
there is a heating set of size s power 3
L for this and my M is so much larger
that by saying that I have a hitting set
for s power 3 l have already got to
there sort of regime that I wanted
the remaining two minutes that I have I
am going to give the proof of the last
step so now we are going to start off
with a hitting set which is barely
non-trivial and I want to make progress
here and at this point sort of it's
crucial that we are going to run this
step of the this step of the proof when
N is truly a constant so some design
parameters now what you do is you need
to work with a the hitting set for
formulas have size something like s /
300 n this seems like a very bad thing
but again let me remind you that n is a
constant so this is something that is
actually doable okay and the reason I'm
doing this is because the individual
degree somehow happens to be slightly
smaller than s / 3 underneath and this
is the sort of regime I meant where I
need to use this hypothesis when the
degree is very close to and so now I
want to make this claim that you know it
preserves the nonzero and s after the
substitution now let's try to do this
but let's try to go through the proof
this will not work as is so let's just
go over the proof what did we do we said
that no even if this turns out to be
zero then there is a small multiple of Q
whose degree is not too large some of
the degree is not the problem such that
it is computable by form allows this
much size
now let's ask ourselves have you got a
contradiction already now the point is
what do I know about Q I know that Q
requires circuits formulas of sizes per
300m so if this quantity was smaller
than s power 300 and beer cool but let's
ask a cell is that the case R equals 2
in this regime so in the sense the
pairwise intersections are 1 but this
already has a component which looks like
a d squared in it and D is very very
large so this is going to give me
something that's much bigger than s /
300 and which seems to be a problem so
it doesn't directly work but it just
needs one additional observation which
is R I mean RR was the pairwise in I
mean it was an upper bound on the strict
upper bound on the pairwise intersection
so here in this case R was equal to 2 so
there was d / R minus 1 D power R minus
1 is the number of monomials and there's
another D outside so this is give me a d
squared and that's currently a problem
so let's look at bedded this term come
from it was the complexity to compute an
R minus 1 Pauline um my R minus 1
variate polynomial of degree D in our
case R is 2 it means this is the
complexity of computing a univariate
polynomial of degree D to say that this
requires d squared is stupid so what we
should be doing is sort of use just
Horner's rule or something to actually
come up with an order D sized formula or
circuit or something to compute it so
this will tell me that you know the the
size of this multiple is actually much
smaller than what we had I mean in the
univariate sitting okay see okay and
then you plug it in and Bob's your uncle
and yeah so this tells you that nonzero
necess preserved once again you can hit
it with Schwartz Apple and you get a
hitting set of the size you want and
that's the full proof okay so I'll just
conclude with some closing remarks ok so
the first thing is that this a similar
statement also works if you start off
with bounded depth models except that
your hypothesis and conclusion have to
be staggered because every time you
apply this records the construction of
the hitting sets I mean you're going to
increase your depth and this
do something like lock star s times so
you will start off with the hypothesis
for a larger depth circuit to get a
final hypothesis for a smaller net
circuit and there's something I want to
mention that it's absolutely crucial
that whatever gain you have in the
exponent is independent of s so it
almost feels like saying that if someone
told me that there is an S to the log s
sized hitting set for size s circuit
this seems like an awesome this is of
course better than brute force but it's
better than brute force only in the
regimes when s is not too large compared
to n but it's crucial another thing that
they'll be points in the algorithm where
you're working with s which is way
bigger than the number of variables and
in those regimes you are not beating
brute force and I don't know how to get
rid of this I would really send a nice
question here as like any start off with
the hypothesis which is more natural in
the sense that suppose you had such a
statement only for poli-sci circuit
these are the sort of circuits we care
about can you make something non-trivial
can we make something non-trivial here
and finally to obtain a hitting set for
a particular size I mean like we start
off with the base hitting set but for
several values for s prime where this X
prime will never be bigger than s bar
tiniest but we need several and the
reason I'm mentioning this is because I
want to know if there is a hardness
amplification type statement that works
in this regime and I mean converse you
know in fact later so and so see I LM
actually have such a statement in the
non commutativity
to sort of start with a sort of decent
lower bound to a really good lower bound
and it seems like I hit once you have a
decent hit i would barely non-trivial
hitting set to super awesome meeting set
ideally it feels like you should be able
to flip it around and convert it to
lower bounds and this is the reason why
we don't seem to have a clean statement
of that sort
[Applause]
and I want to get back to my original
question so can you they get an explicit
description of this PLC or it is a
generator from automatic so it seemed to
be constructing 1:18 sir creates by
hands know who meet you which you
compose with and get another it yes it's
also another polynomial so we found
something very similar so finally what
we did in our last thing is that at the
in the appendix we just wrote down the
code to just the the code is supposed to
just spit out what the heating set for
the final thing is it does do this
composition but the the thing here is
that you need to you need to pick a
different hard polynomial at every level
of the situation
yeah right I don't have a more concise
description of this as a top down sorry
bottom up approach yeah I think about it
last question
[Music]
so I don't know how to do this for
general hardness randomness trade-offs
because I mean unless we know that some
of formulas are closed under factoring
it's in some sense possible that now you
I mean if it was not closed under
factoring maybe there are hard
polynomial such that some multiple
becomes easy so I don't know how to get
around that in the yeah so it's possible
that you know there is a blow-up so is
there a different function Q versus
every multiple of Q's hard
yeah just for you but all its multiple
yeah so there are other contexts in
which the need for this is take on that
wonderful last question
[Applause]